Now that we know what the purpose of the
cache is, and how big approximately it
needs to be, let's look at how
it is organized internally.
The question we need to ask ourselves is
how do we determine if we have a hit or
miss, so we need to know what
data do we have in the cache and
then when the processor gives us
an address, we need to determine whether
that data is or is not in the cache and
we need to do that very quickly.
And the other important question is,
how do we determine
what to kick out from the cache,
once we are out of room in it, and
we need to put more stuff in it,
because we are just having a cache miss.
So, for the first question of, how do we
know whether we have a hit or a miss.
We want something that is very fast.
That means it needs to be a table of
some sort that we can quickly index
with some bits of the address and it
tells us what we have in the cache and
if we do have what we are looking for
then it gives us the data.
So conceptually, the cache is a table
which we index with some bits that we
take from the address of the data.
So some stuff here needs to tell
us whether we have a hit and
the rest of the stuff here is the data
we want if we do have the hit.
How much data we have in each cache
entry is called the block size or
the line size, because the entry in
the cache is also called a line and
they tell us how many bytes
are in each of these entries.
If we have only one byte per entry,
then every address will map
to different to entries.
If you have a block size of one,
that means the entry in
the cache is only one byte.
Every single byte address
will have a different entry.
That creates several problems.
One, usually the processor can issue
accesses not only to a single byte, but
also for example, loadward and storeward
will access a four byte location.
So for a single access,
now we would need to look up four
different lines in the cache.
That complicates and
slows down the cache a lot, so
we definitely don't want
the block size to be this small.
We want the block size to be at
least as large as the largest
single access that we
can do in the cache.
And hopefully slightly larger then that,
just so that when we do a loadward or
storeward we find the data in the same
cache block most of the time.
The next thing that we want to
consider when deciding the block size,
is spatial locality.
If we miss in the cache on one axis,
we will bring in an entire block
worth of memory stuff into the cache.
So if there is no spacial locality,
we want to bring in just what
we are currently accessing.
But if there is any spacial locality,
we want to bring more than
what we are just accessing.
So typically, block sizes of
32 to 128 bytes work well,
both from the perspective of their
larger than a typical access.
And also they capture much of the
spacial locality that exist in programs.
Now let's look at block sizes of
something like 1KB, in that case
what happens is we fetch a lot of data
from memory every time we have a miss,
and if there is not enough locality
a lot of the data will not be used, so
we are occupying space in our cache.
Remember that the cache is only
16 to 64 of these kilobytes.
So if we bring in a block like this,
we are consuming a significant part
of the overall space in the cache.
And we are doing it probably with
data that we won't use much.
So it turns out that for
level one caches at least,
we don't want the block
size to be too large.
So block sizes of 32 to 128
kilobytes are a balance between
getting use of spacial locality
when we bring stuff in,
versus not being dependent
too much on there being
a lot of spacial locality because some
programs don't have that much of it.